the U.S Centers for Disease Control and
prevention otherwise known as the CDC
has faced some major criticisms during
the pandemic ultimately highlighting
that the public health agency failed to
meet the world's expectations so in an
effort to learn from past mistakes its
director has initiated an overhaul meant
to revamp everything from the agency's
operations to its culture I flew down to
its headquarters in Atlanta to ask CDC
director Rachelle wolenski how the
revamp is going
when you first announced moving forward
you laid out your vision for the agency
and how it must evolve and here you said
that the agency was quote responsible
for some pretty dramatic pretty public
mistakes now that was that was quite
candid and I wonder what examples you
were thinking of when you shared that
message internally with CDC staff it
wasn't hard to find headlines of places
where CDC was taken heat one of them of
course was the lab and the early
diagnostic test that came out and others
have just been confusing and complicated
messages great news this week the CDC
announced that fully vaccinated people
no longer have to wear masks or socially
distance except if you go to most places
early on our guidance was very technical
we were not necessarily accustomed to
having our guidance be a place where
every American would click on CDC and
and read our school guidance or read our
quarantine guidance but that's how it
was being utilized now so we had to rise
to the occasion
so one of those components was really
delivering our science in real time when
we knew it and then the second is sing
it in plain language what does this mean
what are the things that it doesn't say
what are the things that it does say and
what is still unknown among the changes
Dr wilenski will require all employees
be ready to deploy to combat Health
crises marking a drastic shift from a
volunteer system the agency relied on to
staff its covid-19 response
it is difficult with multiple responses
to have the same people respond again
and again and again and so what we need
to do really is to make sure that every
person in this agency actually considers
response as a critical element of their
job there's a number of activities that
we're doing now to sort of move in that
direction I think there's a lot of
challenges that were overcoming we were
very siled the way we respond to various
threats before covid-19 the level of the
response needed really required us to
work across the agency to pull together
what I wanted that restructuring to
reflect is high visibility
accountability within the agency and
what are those key places that we really
need to be responsible so things like
our laboratory our office of science our
Public Health infrastructure and
Workforce I really want to decrease
layers of reporting decrease the
bureaucracy if you will
[Music]
we're in a bsl4 laboratory training
facility biosafety level four yes we
train people so that they can work
safely and effectively when they're
really dealing with the most pathogenic
agents that we have things like smallpox
Ebola when we looked at what's happened
in the pandemic there were really three
things we want to do better the first is
we can't have a test that goes out that
doesn't have a thorough enough quality
review the second thing we need to get
it as fast as possible to the private
sector and the third thing we want to
make sure we stay on top of the best
Technologies because we would like to
have tests like the tests that you get
in drug stores but to be as accurate as
the PCR test
I heard a lot of optimism from CDC staff
about their plans to move forward but
one potential obstacle is Congress
funding is a place we've seen Congress
reach a roadblock I mean what kind of
resources will it take to execute the
strategy that you've laid out one of the
challenges of CDC when I got here was
that we were working off a frail
underfunded Public Health infrastructure
not just a CDC but around the country
there have been data that have suggested
that the workforce is 80 000 public
health workers in deficit wow when you
start with that infrastructure and you
layer on top of it a global pandemic
that affects 330 million Americans you
you have challenges at the get-go moving
forward in my mind is really a lot about
what's the best most efficient way that
we can take the resources that we have
right now and leverage them to do the
best that we can within CDC there will
be areas and places where we will ask
for additional resources in our public
Health infrastructure in our data
modernization efforts in our laboratory
capacity and then there will be places
that we fully recognize that we're going
to need Congressional help in order to
be nimble
I want to talk about politics for a
moment because science has become
political I wonder what the toll of that
has been on the CDC sometimes it's
harder in a politically charged
environment but our job is to deliver
Health in a bipartisan way I always go
back to when I'm standing in front of a
patient they don't necessarily challenge
the reason that you're there they know
that you're there to care for them this
agency perceives the country as their
patient so the most important thing that
we do is put our head down do the
science Public Health action-oriented
work to deliver Health we're going to
need to demonstrate that regardless of
the political powers that are out there
foreign
[Music]